it's the trade-off between because of
somebody technologist right they want to
say about technology I call it like the
hacker mentality of they're you know
they're tinkering they make technology
do something that they haven't seen
before or it's faster it's better or
whatever and they start showing people
people get excited but I think there's
too much focus on that technology and
instead if you look at it the opposite
side say let's look at it from user
behavior right now the user actually
doesn't care what's under the hood right
the or there's some users that will
write obviously there's some small
subset but but the mass consumer mass
user doesn't actually care what that
technology is they just want to
accomplish what they're trying to do
with the technology but I think this is
part of the challenge when you have a
movement that really started with
engineering and technology is you have a
bunch of developers and engineers who
for the first time are discovering
finance and they're saying oh we can
treat finance like code and there's an
input and then there's a contract and
then there's output and the thing is
like you and I worked in traditional
finance that's not how people think you
people don't respond to an input
function with a particular output and I
think my friend Jill Carlson says it
best it's not you put in a token you get
out in action that's not how incentives
and systems work it's a little bit more
complex than that because human beings
react to emotion human beings I think
are fundamentally irrational and again
behavioral finance is a field of study
that's only really you know half a
century old 50 60 years old and we're
still learning a lot look at what
happened in 2008 not a lot of people saw
that coming look at what happens in
individual asset classes we have all
these great ideas and what we see is the
breakdown of markets um look at the
equities market right now look at the
fangs right it's an imperfect science
but I think treating crypto like a math
problem treating it like an engineering
problem treating finance and money in
that manner is interesting but I don't
think that works and so I think the next
five to ten years are probably going to
be spent trying to figure out how to
integrate other disciplines into